I'd like to welcome people to introduction to psychology.
My name is Dr. Paul Bloom and I'm a professor for this course.
Uh,
if you haven't yet picked up a syllabus from the front of the class,
please raise your hand or are we out or we had to celebrate.
Oh,
please raise your hand.
And when the teaching fellows will bring it to you,
if you don't yet have a several of us.
MMM.
The syllabus is also available on this website.
This website will become important to you should you choose to take this class.
Um,
it will include the syllabus which will occasionally be revised,
um,
well in advance.
Also,
all of the class material will be on this site,
including copies of the slides I'm presenting,
including these slides right now,
um,
practice exam and any details on the written assignments.
So you'll need to use this website regularly.
Um,
the keep in touch with the course today will be a short class.
what I just want to do today is orient you,
tell you what this course is about.
Um,
I know this is shopping period and I want to give you a good sense of what you'd
be in for.
If you took this course.
I want to go over the style of the classes,
the valuation,
the readings and so on.
Um,
and then give some examples of some of the specific topics that we'll be
covering.
But before I get started,
I have to point out something a little bit unusual about this class.
Um,
we are being filmed,
this course is one of seven courses chosen to begin the Yale University open
educational resources video lecture project.
Um,
and what this means is that when the year is over,
um,
these videos will be available on the Internet free for anybody who wants to see
them,
um,
and ideally will be accessed by people across many different countries.
Some hood would not normally have access to a university education.
Um,
I see this as a good and honorable use of Yale's resources.
And of course it's also part of Yale's plan for world domination.
So because of this,
a Yale University production team from the center of media initiatives is going
to be taping all the class lectures and they're up there.
Um,
the idea is that this should be as unobtrusive as possible.
and the classroom experience should essentially be the same as if they're not
there.
So it was their intention to tape the lectures to tape me and sometimes,
uh,
the,
the slides but not tape your faces or voices.
So we're not having you sign release forms.
Um,
two things.
One thing is personally,
um,
I have to remind myself not to use profanity because children may be watching.
So I'll try not to do that.
Um,
there was also another complexity.
If you are in the front row or the second row or third row,
it is possible that some part of your head,
your back or even your face might end up on film.
Um,
if,
if you are in the witness protection program or you are some sort of fugitive,
you probably don't want to sit in the front row.
Um,
I'll give him,
if people want to unobtrusively kind of slide back.
That's fine as I'm talking.
Okay.
We're ready.
So I like to injured to,
um,
welcome people to this course.
Introduction to psychology.
My name is Dr. Paul Bloom.
I'm professor of this course.
Um,
and what this is going to be
is a comprehensive introduction to the study of the human mind.
So we're going to cover a very,
very wide range of topics including brains,
children,
language,
sex,
memory,
badness,
discuss racism and love and many others.
We're going to talk about things like the proper explanation for differences
between men and women.
Um,
the question of whether animals can learn language,
the puzzle of what grosses is,
help the problem of why some of us eat too much and what we could do to stop the
question of why people go crazy in groups.
Research into whether you can trust your childhood memories,
research into why some of us get depressed and others don't.
The style of this is there'll be two lectures a week
as well as course readings now to do well in the course.
Um,
you have to attend both the lectures and do the readings.
There will be some overlap.
In some cases the lectures will be quite linked to the readings,
but there will be some cute parts of the readings that will not find her way
into the lectures and some lecture,
some entire lectures that will not connect at all to the readings.
So to pursue this course properly,
you have to do both.
Um,
what this means is that if you miss a class,
you need to get notes.
And so you should get them from a friend or from the person sitting next to you.
The slides are going to be made available online.
So one of the things you don't have to do is you don't have to write this down.
You take notes any way you choose,
but if you don't get anything on there,
it'll be available online.
I'm going to post it in a format which will be black and white and,
and easy to print out so you don't have to worry about this.
But again,
attending to the slide is not a substitute for attending class.
There's a textbook.
Um,
Peter Gray's psychology fifth edition and there's also a collection of short
readings,
the Norton reader edited by Gary Marcus.
Um,
it's an excellent textbook.
It's an extra from collection and you should get them both.
Um,
they're available at labyrinth bookstore on York street or if you get them
online,
I should note that last time I taught the course I used the Marcus reader and
um,
when Professor Marvin Chan taught his course last semester,
he used Peter Gray's fifth edition textbook,
sort of maybe a lot of used copies floating around.
You should feel free to try to get one of those.
The evaluation goes like this.
There is a midterm and there's a final,
the final will not be held in the exam period because I like to take long
vacations.
It will be held the last day of class.
The exams will mean we'll be multiple choice and short answer,
fill in the blank,
that sort of thing.
Prior to the exams,
I will post previous exams online so you have a feeling for how these exams work
and so on.
There will also be review sessions starting at the beginning of the third week
of class.
That is not next week,
but the week after.
On Monday,
each Monday I'm going to put up a brief question or set of questions which you
have to answer and your answers need to be sent to your teaching fellow and
you'll be given a teaching fellow assigned one.
Um,
by Friday.
This is not meant to be difficult,
it's not meant to be more than five,
10 minutes of work,
but the point of the question,
1520 minutes of work.
Um,
but the point of the question is to motivate people to keep up with the material
and do the readings.
These questions will be marked pass,
fail.
I expect most everybody to pass all of the questions but it's just to keep you
on track and keep you going.
Um,
there's a book review,
a short book review to be written towards near the end of the class.
I'll give details about that later on in the semester and there's also an
experimental participation requirement.
And next week I'll,
I'll hand out a piece of paper describing the requirement.
The point of the requirement is to give you all experience actually seeing what
psychological research is about as well as to give us hundreds of subjects to do
our experiments on.
Um,
the issue sometimes comes up as the how to do well in the course.
here's how to do well at 10 all the classes.
Keep up with the readings.
Ideally keep up with the readings before you come to class.
Um,
and one thing I would strongly suggest is to form some sort of study groups,
either formally or informally,
have people you could talk to when the exact prior to the exams or she's patting
somebody next to her.
I hope you know him.
Um,
and um,
and,
and in fact what I want to do,
not this class cause it's dropping appeared.
I don't know who's coming next class or what,
but I'll set up a few minutes prior at the beginning of class for people just to
introduce themselves to the person next to them so they have some sort of
resource,
um,
in the class.
Now this is a large class.
Um,
and if you don't do anything about it,
it can be very anonymous and some of you may choose to pursue it that way and
it's totally fine.
But what I would suggest you do is establish some contact with us,
either with me or with any of the teaching fellows and I'll introduce the
teaching fellows sometime next week.
Um,
you could talk to us at the beginning or the end of class unless you're special
circumstances.
I always try to come at least 10 minutes early and I try and I'm willing to stay
late to talk to people.
Um,
you could come by during my office hours,
which are on the syllabus and you can send me email and set up an appointment.
Um,
I'm very willing to talk to students about intellectual ideas,
about chorus problems and so on.
And if you see me at some point just on campus,
um,
you could introduce yourself and I,
I'd like to meet people from this class.
Um,
so again,
I learned a stress.
You have the option of staying anonymous in this class,
but you also have the option of seeking out and making some sort of contact with
us.
Okay.
That's the formal stuff of the course.
What's this course about?
Um,
unlike a lot of other courses,
some people come to intro psychology with some unusual motivations.
Um,
maybe you're crazy and hope to become less crazy.
maybe you want to learn how to study better,
improve your sex life,
interpret your dreams and win friends and influence people.
Those are not necessarily bad reasons to take this course and with the exception
of the sex part,
um,
this course might actually help you out with some of these things.
The study of scientific psychology has a lot of insight of real world relevance
to real problems that we face in our everyday lives.
And I want to try it.
And when these issues come up,
I'm going to try to stress them and,
and,
and make you try to think about the extent to which the laboratory research I'll
be talking about can affect your everyday life,
how you study,
how you interact with people,
how you might try to persuade somebody of something else,
what sort of therapy works best for you.
Um,
but the general goals of this course are actually,
I think even more interesting than that.
What I want to do is provide a state of the art introduction to the most
important topic that there is,
um,
us.
How the human mind works,
how we think,
what makes us,
what we are.
And we'll be approaching this from a range of directions.
So traditionally psychology often broken up into the following in into five
subareas neuroscience,
which is the study of the,
of the mind by looking at the brain developmental,
which is the area which I focused mostly on,
which is trying to learn about how people develop and grow and learn.
Cognitive,
which is the one term of the five that might be unfamiliar to some of you,
but it refers to a sort of computational approach to studying the mind.
Often viewing the mind on analogy with a computer and looking at how people do
things like understand language,
recognize objects,
play games and so on.
There is social,
which is the study of how people act in groups,
how people act with other people.
And there is clinical,
which is maybe the aspect of psychology that people think of immediately when
they hear psychology,
which is a study of mental health and mental illness.
And we'll be covering all of those areas.
We'll also be covering a set of related areas.
I am convinced that you cannot study the mind solely by looking at the
discipline of psychology to,
this is one that psychology spills over the issues of how the mind has evolved.
Um,
economics and game theory are now an essential tools for understanding human
thought and human behavior.
There was issues connecting to philosophy,
computer science,
anthropology,
literature,
theology,
and many,
many other domains.
So this course will be wide ranging in that sense.
Um,
at this point I've been speaking in generalities.
So I want to close this introductory class by giving five examples of the sorts
of topics we'll be covering.
And I'll start off the topic that we'll be covering next week on Monday the
brain.
Um,
this is a brain,
in fact,
it's a specific person's brain
and with interesting,
but the brain is that little white mark there.
Okay?
It's her brain.
It's Terry Shabbos brain.
You recognize her more from pictures like that.
And what a case like this,
where somebody's,
um,
is,
is in a coma,
is without consciousness as a result of damage to the brain is a stark
illustration of the physical nature of mental life,
the physical basis for everything that we normally hold dear,
like freewill consciousness,
morality,
and our emotions.
And that's what we'll begin the course with talking about how a physical thing
can give rise to mental life.
Okay.
We'll talk a lot about children.
This is actually a specific child.
My son Zachary,
a younger son,
um,
dressed up as superman,
Spiderman,
but it is Halloween.
No,
it's not Halloween.
Oh Wow.
There's more to say about that.
Um,
I studied child development for a living and I'm interested in several
questions.
So one question is just a question of development.
Everybody in this room can speak and understand English.
Everybody in this room has some understanding how the world works,
how physical things behave.
Everybody in this room has some understanding of other people and how people
behave.
And the question that that preoccupies developmental psychologist is how do we
come to have this knowledge?
And in particular how much of it is it hardwired built in in ne and how much of
it is a product of culture,
of,
of language,
of schooling and developmental psychologists use many ingenious methods to try
to pull these apart and try to figure out what,
what,
what's,
what are the basic components of human nature?
There's also the question of continuity.
To what extent is that accurate at that age going to be that way forever.
To what extent is your fate sealed?
To what extent could,
if I were to me when you were five years old,
I could describe the way you are now.
Um,
the poet William Wordsworth wrote,
the child is father to the man.
And what this means is that you can see within every child the adult he or she
will become.
Um,
we will look and,
and,
and ask the question whether this is true.
Is it true for your personality?
Is it true for your interest?
Is it true for your intelligence?
Another question having to do with development
is what makes us the way we are.
We're different in a lot of ways.
The people in this room differ according to their tastes in food.
They differ according to their ICUs,
whether they're aggressive or shy,
whether they're attracted to males,
females,
both or neither.
Whether whether they are good at music,
whether they're politically liberal or conservative.
Why are we different?
What's the explanation for why we're different?
And again,
this could be translated in terms of a question of genes and environment.
To what extent are things the result of the genes we possess?
To what extent are our,
our individual natures the result of how we were raised and to what extent are
they best explained in terms of an interaction?
One common theory for instance is that we are shaped by our parents.
Um,
this was best summarize most famously by the British poet Philip Larkin
who wrote,
they mess you up,
your mom and dad,
they may not mean to,
but they do,
they fill you with the false they had and add some extra just for you.
Is he right,
is very controversial.
You,
it's been a series of a huge controversy in popular culture to the extent to
which parents matter.
And this is an issue which will preoccupy us for much of the course.
A different question.
What makes somebody attractive?
And this can be acid,
all sorts of levels,
but as symbol level is what makes for a pretty face.
So these are according to ratings,
very attractive faces.
They are not the faces of real people.
What's on the screen are computer generated faces,
um,
a a Caucasian male and a Caucasian female who don't exist in the real world.
But through using this sort of computer generation and then asking people what
they think of this face,
what they think of that phase.
Scientists have come to some sense as to what really makes a face attractive
both within cultures and across cultures.
And that's something which we're going to devote some time to when we talk about
social behavior.
And in particular when we talk about sex,
um,
not all attractiveness,
not all beauty of course is linked to sex.
Um,
so,
so pan does for instance,
like this panda are notoriously cute and I don't,
I don't have anything to say about it really.
It's just a cute picture.
Okay.
Um,
morality is extremely central to our lives and a deep question which we will
struggle with throughout most of the course is the question of good and evil,
evil and good.
Um,
these three pictures exemplify different sorts of evil.
We can call institutional evil,
um,
by somebody
behaving cruelly to report somebody for somebody else.
Perhaps not due to malice,
but because of the situation that she's in,
it has a picture of Osama bin Ladin um,
a mass murderer or driven by political cause.
And then there's this guy on the bottom.
Anybody know who he is?
Ted Bundy who got that film,
that man.
No.
Ted Bundy.
Exactly.
And that's like I,
before we get into the technical stuff,
like crazy evil and,
and,
and we're going to have to come to terms with why some people are like that.
And again,
the same situation comes up.
Is it part of your nature to be good or bad?
Um,
or is it largely due to the situation that you,
that you fallen?
And there's a lot of,
some quite spectacular experiments that try to tease that apart.
If we're going to talk about evil,
we should also talk about good.
Um,
this is,
these are pictures of,
um,
of two notoriously Goodman,
Oscar Schindler and Paul recessive,
but Ganja,
um,
each who at different times in history,
save the lives of many,
many people at great risk to themselves.
Um,
she didn't learn the Holocaust.
and,
and then the other guy in,
and I'm good,
I can't pronounce his name.
Recessive again.
Yeah.
Um,
in Rwanda.
And they both had real good movies made about them.
Um,
and,
and so,
but,
but what's interesting with these cases is you couldn't have predicted ahead of
time that day would be heroes.
And one personal issue within any of us is what would we do in such situations.
Um,
finally throughout this course we will discuss mental illness.
Now towards the end of the class,
I want to devote a full week to discussing major or disorders like depression
and anxiety because of their profound social importance.
Um,
such disorders are reasonably common in college students.
Uh,
many people in this room are currently suffering from a mood disorder and
anxiety disorder or both.
And I won't ask for a show of hands,
but I know a lot of people in this room are on some form of medication for this
disorder.
Um,
and we'll discuss,
we'll discuss the current research and why people get these disorders and what's
the best way to make them better.
But I also have a weakness for the less common mental disorders that I think
tell us something really interesting about mental life.
So when we talk about memory,
for instance,
we'll talk about disorders and memory,
including some disorders that keep you from forming new memories as well as all
disorders of Amnesia where you forget the past.
And these are an extraordinarily interesting for all sorts of reasons.
Early in the course.
In fact,
I think next week we will discuss later on in the course in the middle of middle
of the semester,
we will discuss the amazing case of Phineas gage.
Phineas gage was a construction worker,
but a hundred years ago due to an explosion,
a metal pipe went through his head like so miraculously he was not killed.
In fact,
his friends and it went through his head when ended up a hundred feet away,
covered with brains and blood and Phineas gage.
You sat down and then on the way to the hospital they stopped by a pub,
have some cider.
He was not blind,
he was not deaf.
He was not retarded,
but something else happened to them.
He lost a sense of right and wrong.
He lost his control.
He used to be a hardworking family man.
After the accident,
he lost all of that.
He couldn't hold a job.
He couldn't stay faithful to his wife.
He couldn't speak for five minutes without cursing.
He got into fights.
You got into browse,
he got drunk,
he lost his control.
He ended up on a circus side show traveling through the country with the big
steel pipe that went through his head.
Yeah,
and this is again an extraordinary example of how the brain can give rise to the
mind and how things that go wrong with the brain can affect you in a serious
way.
We'll discuss cases and multiple personality disorder where people have more
than one personality and also discuss the debate over wet weather.
Such cases are true or not.
Whether they can be taken as a real phenomena or have made up phenomena,
which is,
there's a matter of a lot of controversy and then we'll even discuss some rarer
cases.
Um,
like capgras syndrome.
[inaudible] Syndrome is typically,
is,
there's hundreds of cases,
not many hundreds of cases.
It's typically the result of some sort of stroke.
And what happens to you is very specific.
You develop a particular delusion,
like it's getting dark.
And the delusion is that the people you love the most have been replaced.
They've been replaced by aliens or robots.
Thank you.
Um,
by,
by Martians,
by CIA agents,
by trained actors and actresses.
But the people,
okay.
But the idea is the people you care for the most you believe are gone.
And
this could lead to tragic consequences.
Cop Grass Syndrome is associated with a very high level of violence.
Um,
one man in Australia a couple of years ago was under the delusion that his
father was replaced with a robot and cut off his head.
Okay.
Uh,
related disorder involving the very same parts of the brain is called
[inaudible] syndrome and could tarnish syndrome is you believe that you're dead.
Yeah.
You believe that your dad,
you,
you are persuaded that you're dead.
You're walking around,
you know,
you're walking around and you know that there are people around.
Um,
but you think that you're dead.
And what's striking about these is it's not,
these are not just sort of big screwy problems of messed up people.
Rather they're located,
they're related at a pinpoint level to certain parts of your brain and we're
going to talk about the best modern theories as to why these syndromes occur.
Now the reason to be interested in them again is not because they're frequent,
they aren't and it's not because of some sort of gruesome morbid curiosity.
Rather by looking at extreme cases,
they can help us best understand normal life.
Often by looking at extremes,
it's rose into sharp contrast things we naturally take for granted.
The issue of of psychopathy,
of people who either due to brain damage or because they born that way have no
moral understanding can help us cope with questions of freewill and
responsibility of the relationship or difference between mental illness and
evil.
Multiple personality cases forced us to address the question of what is a self,
what to what extent do are all of us compose the multiple people and to what
extent are we a single unified person over time?
Cases like cop grass
yeah,
are important because they tell us about how we see the world.
They tell us,
for instance,
that there's a difference between recognizing something in a sense that you can
name it and knowing what it is and,
and,
and so by studying these abnormal cases,
we can get some insight into regular life.
So that's the end of the illustration of the example topics.
The syllabus lists many more.
I'll end by telling you that
there's a little,
there's a lot of stuff that we'll be talking about that I want to talk about
that I am not expert in.
And fortunately there is a community at Yale of the best scholars and teachers
on the planet.
And so it would be a shame for me not to use them to cover some of these issues.
And so I want to include four guests lectures.
The first one is doctor Marvin Chan,
who is teaches introduction to psychology course in the fall and as my
competition.
Um,
and he's going to give an amazing lecture on cognitive neuroscience,
especially the cognitive neuroscience of faces.
Dr. Susan Nolan Eczema is the world's authority on depression and in particular
on sex differences in depression.
And she's going to talk about this towards the end of the course.
Kelly Brown hell,
um,
is going to target is the head of the Rudd Center,
focuses on obesity,
eating disorders,
dieting,
and he'll talk about the psychology of food.
And finally,
um,
Dr Peter Salivate,
I'm dean of Yale College,
is going to come to us on Valentine's Day and tell us everything he knows about
the mysteries of love.
All of these details are in the syllabus.
Um,
and I'll stick around and answer questions.
Hope to see you next week.